Hana too is distraught she's barely
slept for weeks since the disappearance
of her 18 year old daughter the girl was
taking exams at school back in April
when she was kidnapped by Boko Haram
terrorists if that then I come my
daughter loves sewing after school she
dreamed of buying her own sewing machine
after she finished her exams Nakamura
mocha and then she wanted to start her
own business my daughter is a very sweet
and modest person but a Tubba sediba
heart I gilma a Hannah here in chibok in
the northeast of Nigeria her daughter
and nearly 300 other girls were
kidnapped loaded onto trucks and driven
away the school was destroyed and now
has been closed this pile of abandoned
clothing in a classroom is the last
remaining sign the missing girls locals
complain of a lack of security forces on
Sunday Boko Haram struck again attacking
nearby villages I'm not done groaning
the federal government but the federal
government has proved to us that they
are not up to the task of bringing back
all gasp even virtually two months today
and nothing has been done so we don't
have any confidence in the federal
government frustration and anger here in
the northeast of Nigeria are increasing
every day the parents of the abducted
girls can't understand why the
government is not able to bring back
their children despite all the promises
and the international support instead
Boko Haram is bombing and killing people
every day and throughout the region
further back into turmoil in the capital
Abuja the government is working to bring
the girls home safely Deutsche Welle
sources suggest they have been split
into three groups and that authorities
know where they are but intervention is
seen as an unacceptably high risk you
don't use a bull in a china shop
approach when you have such delicate
lives
held hostage and you know how deadly
hostage situation should be you want to
optimize your intelligence when optimize
your thinking the best approach to to
rescue in those girls Hannah to holds
out hope that negotiations will secure
her daughter's safe return even if Boko
Haram is demanding the release of
prisoners as a swamp